kommt zur heutigen sitzung in der wir
beide und sie uns vor allem mit martin
luther werden martin luther ist ganz
zentral in dieser thematik die sünde und
das böse weil ich noch sehen werden ganz
viele bezüge hergestellt hat in seinen
schriften zu den positionen die wir
bereits hatten zur letzten sitzung zu
der wir heute aber auch noch mal kurz
kommen werden zur last sich mit thomas
von aquin es gegen die scholastik welche
argumente bringt dagegen die chance sich
vor dann ist augustinus ein bezugspunkt
bei ihm und der mann ist muss ist ein
bezugspunkt bei ihm also alle positionen
die wir bisher hatten kommen bei luther
wieder vor und werden eine ganz neue
ordnung gebracht wir werden heute auch
ein referat hören über luther das machen
wir aber würde ich würden wir vorschlag
in der hälfte dieser sitzung weil wir zu
beginn noch etwas zurückgehen wollen auf
thomas mack wien den wir in der letzten
sitzung nicht ganz zu ende besprechen
konnten wir haben ja ein sehr sehr
anspruchsvolles pensum uns vorgenommen
jedes sitzung einen großen denker eine
große denkerin durch die philosophie
geschichte hindurch der nachteil einer
solchen methode danke ist der dass man
vielleicht nicht ganz so ins detail
gehen kann das können sie dann aber in
ihren hausarbeiten machen der große
vorteil auf den es uns an kann ist der
dass man schön die zusammenhänge sie
ganz großen lieben die
ideengeschichtliche linien die
begriffsgeschichte ideengeschichte wie
haben sich die bittere verändert welche
neuen perspektiven kam ins spiel
das ist also unser motivation des
seminars dann ganz zu beginn noch ein
bisschen werbung in eigener sache
sie haben schon mitbekommen es gibt
einen neuen youtube-kanal der heißt viel
lowcost und dazu möchte ich auch noch
mal ein paar flyer herumgehen lassen
sie werden zehn genau auch hier ein
bisschen einfach mal rumgehen lassen
genau dieser kanal ist also recht neu
und sie werden sehen wenn sie mal darauf
gehend dass eine neue sendung drauf ist
nämlich die aufzeichnung der letzten
sitzung als die letzte sitzung können
sie nach hören und sie können auch die
diskussion mit verfolgen wir haben die
folien der letzten sitzung auch darauf
gestellt und auch die heutige sitzung
wird wenn es gut läuft wieder
aufgezeichnet werden
finden sie alles auf filou kaarst dazu
gibt es natürlich auch app das habe ich
schon gesagt sie können alle inhalte und
auch die zusammenfassung hallo auch die
zusammenfassung die wir immer rum
schicken die finden sie auch in der app
zum durch diese inhalte gibt es auch auf
der app zum nachlesen das noch so ein
bisschen ankündigung vorab dann kommen
wir noch mal ganz kurz auf thomas von
aquin zurück danke und da hatten wir ja
uns vorher noch überlegt wie es aussieht
mit der prävention stereo mit der
perversion story das sind ja so die
haupt koordinaten entlang deren wir die
verschiedenen theorien uns näher ansehen
und jetzt unsere rückfrage nochmal
anzieht zur einstimmung zum beginn was
ist noch mal eine prävention story des
bösen und was es mit perversion story
das haben sie dann nochmal ideen dazu
was hatten wir gesagt hat es damit auf
sich
mal vom wort kommen von der
wortbedeutung kommen
ja bitte
genau also wir hatten gesagt das böse
ist ein mangel an guten mangel ist die
private krieges der ss die beraubung
auch privat ist der ist für sich das ist
ein mangel an guten und dann gibt es
eben noch eine steigerung dass er sagt
das gute ist dass sein oder sein ist das
gute das kennen sie von platon her die
die griechen haben immer dass das
höchste mit dem gut die idee des guten
verbunden und das ist auch das
eigentlich seien der oder bei platten
soll auch das über dem sein entstehende
das pekinger theresias des jenseits des
seins spielte das schöne gute ware
sie kennen vielleicht auch in der
mittelalterlichen tradition diese
transzendentale nur um das eine währung
das wahre problem dass gute erster sein
und so weiter und so fort die die sind
alles sehr eng verknüpft und deswegen
kann man sagen es ist nicht nur ein
mangel an guten sondern auch ein mangel
des seins es ist also logisch de
potenziert es stellt sich die frage nach
der realität des bösen hat es eine
eigenständige realität oder ist es nur
ein abglanz und scheinen die platonische
theorie liegt nahe dass das böse nur so
ein schein ist wie so ein schattenbild
verglichen mit den wahren dingen und den
bildern
dem entgegen steht die perversion
theorie
da steckt auch schon drin sie könnte ich
das sehr einfach merken dem sie einfach
auf das wort schauen perversion
das böse ist ein aktive verkehrung
perversion also per heißt um und version
von weitere um wendung umwälzung des
guten das gegen gute und unter logisch
eigenständig das hat der eigene realität
es ist nicht nur ein mangel an seinen
mangel an guten das hat einen eigenen
sound status der eigene logik und nicht
nur eine mangelhaftigkeit da steckt eine
positive tät drin
und zwischen diesen zwei positionen
schwanken alle theorien die wir
behandeln werden auch diejenige von
thomas von aquin obwohl die wie sie
sicherlich schon herausgefunden haben
ihr diese präventions- theorie nahe
steht aber es finden sich bestimmt auch
ansätze von perversion theoretischen
momenten und dass wir auch immer eine
gute idee mit blick auf ihre hausarbeit
wenn sie eine schreiben wollen sie
könnten ganz einfach sich ein denker
eine denkerin vornehmen und sie mal
daraufhin untersuchen ob sich ansätze
von präventions- oder perversion
theoretischen momenten finden werden vom
abhandeln genau das wollten wir beide
noch mal kurz zu beginn voran schicken
weil das sehr wichtige begriffe sind und
dann könnten wir jetzt noch mal ganz
kurz zurückgehen auf thomas von der
queen wir nehmen noch ein paar zitate
durch die wir nicht behandeln konnten
wir hatten ein paar leitfragen wie für
thomas von aquin deprivation story des
bösen welt lassen sich beim auch ansätze
eine perversion szenerie finden wie kann
thomas dafür argumentieren dass das böse
zugleich unbeabsichtigt und der noch
willentlich ist da hast immer auch in
der zusammenfassung kurz darauf
eingegangen
und das ist eine spannende frage nach
inwiefern kann thomas von der queen
behaupten dass das gute die ursache des
schlechten ist ist das nicht
widersprüchlich kann das gute das
überhaupt sein
na ja das können wir einfach nur mal
hier der reihe nachlesen für ein paar
zitate
vielleicht wollen sie mal hier anfangen
dass sie einfach mal dass am lesen
ja
im schlechten
das sind in deutschland
vielen dank
was halten sie von dieser auffassung
leuchtete ihn ein und wege theorie
finden sie dort am ehesten enthalten
deprivation street perversen uns theorie
haben sie da schon ideen
sie sagen jetzt dass schlechte er
spricht er von dem schlechten dadurch
dass das substantiiert könnte man der
auffassung seien dass schlecht das mal
um hat eine eigenständige realität von
dem wir abgestoßen werden wenn die
möglichkeit aber jetzt überlegen sie mal
dieses abgestoßen werden
es ist fliehen könnte man das nicht auch
privat ions theoretisch verstehen könnte
sicherlich sagen wie sie es tun dadurch
also vom schlechten als solchem spricht
spricht nicht nur von einem mangel das
schlechte existiert zu das sicherlich
richtig aber gibt sich noch auch ansätze
eine privat ions theorie die hier
enthalten sind
vielleicht ein bisschen schwierig peter
oder dana hier
ich denke das geht in die richtige
richtung ja ja ja und er sich dann aber
täuschen würde darin ja und er
vielleicht auch dann irgendwie im sog
dieser sucht wäre und gar nicht
eigenständig handeln könnte ich denke
was wichtig ist wenn sie auf diese
bewegungsrichtungen schauen also es geht
mein fliehen und anstreben
die frage ist hier kann man könnte man
nicht auch nach dem bösen streben das
streben ist eine aktivität das ist ja
was willentlich ist und hier scheint das
böse nur flieger zu sein aber nicht
erstrebt da zu sein und das spricht
etwas gegen die perversion theorie weil
die perversion story scheint zu erlauben
dass man auch nach dem bösen strebt will
endlich aktiv und das ist ihr so zu
verstehen als ob uns das böse abstößt
werden einfach abgestoßen
das böse ist los zerstörung das will
jeder von sich aus schon vermeiden und
nur das gute zieht an nur das gute ist
das was man eigentlich wirklich
erstreben kann dass da liegt schon so
eine einrichtung der per se der
präventions- theorie vertreten
aber es ist nicht ganz so leicht wir
lesen vielleicht ist es nicht ganz so
klar da gebe ich recht du hast noch
das ist ganz ganz italien interessant
auch wenn man sich mit mittelalterlicher
musik beschäftigt man kann das ganz
schön zeigen die schwierigsten
mittlerweile eingemeindet
semantisch so zu fassen das ist das
wesen was sie beschreiben auch wirklich
damit bezeichnet also wir sind also
vorstellen da eingegangen dass das
schlechter weil sie als substantiv
besteht natürlich den charakter von
etwas das ist nämlich geben und so lief
die argumentationen mittelalter im
universalen streit ist der allgemein
betrifft in unserem strategien kann ein
ähnlicher beschreibt in siders und alles
aus mir anklicken objektive ist
dementsprechend lehrer an den seiten und
dran hängen ein aktien der metis und und
dass das ist hier ganz gut klar dass er
vielleicht kann man es am schönsten wir
schreiben mit
die vergangenheit ist vergangenheit
meine meinung
von dem her kann man etwas geld was
erinnerungen orte erlebnisse bestimmte
tage bestimmten zeitpunkt und zweiter
welle die vergangenheit selbst gibt es
nicht nur in den zeitungen greifen
könnte es so nicht gibt und so ähnlich
schaltet sich das was mir vorzustellen
wie schlecht man kann
zum schlechten anstreben würden
die
in zukunft vielleicht eine zeit zurück
seiten verschieden aber nicht
das ist genau die dimension in der das
mittelalter
finde ich finde ich sehr sehr in ein
leuchtendes beispiel was du da gegeben
hast
wir sehen uns also sehr tricky hier
diese ganze show lastige und luther wie
wir noch sehen werden wendet sich gegen
solche argumentationsweise die frage ist
ob luther darin nicht auch wieder
solistisch ist oder so was
aber wir gehen mal weiter ich lese
einfach mal vor dieses zitat daraus wird
deutlich dass ich das schlechte mal um
in den dingen ohne absicht des tätigen
einstellt was nämlich im unterschied zu
dem was vom tätigen beabsichtigt war
aus dessen tätigkeit hervorgeht das
geschieht offensichtlich unbeabsichtigt
das schlechte ist aber von dem guten
verschieden und auch jedes tätige strebt
also tritt das schlechte unbeabsichtigt
ein
das ist wieder mit dem letzten zar
zusammengebracht diese konto logische
der potenzierung das schlechte ist
nichts was wirklich will endlich aktiv
erstrebt wird davon fliehen wir nachher
fliehen von dem schlechten wird
abgestoßen
wir sind darin fast schon unfrei uns
dazu zu verhalten und darin zeigt sich
wieder so eine prävention
dann sagt er vielleicht gibts noch ein
paar andere sachen
ich gebe ein bisschen weiter es gibt
jetzt viele zitate die wir noch haben
aber ich möchte dass es nochmal
wichtigste tat hier das schlechte ist
nämlich wie gesagt nichts anderes als
die privaten dessen auf dessen besitz
man von natur aus angelegt ist und das
man haben muss so ist bei allen der
gebrauch des wortes schlechtes die
prävention ist aber kein wesens eine
negation in der substanz sagt
aristoteles das schlechte ist also kein
wesen in den dingen vielleicht wichtiges
zitat sehen sie noch mal hier
das schlechte betrifft nicht die
substanz nicht das wesen nicht eine
ökologische eigenständigkeit sind nur
etwas an etwas 1 aktie den zehn zufällig
hinkommen dass eine wesentliche
eigenschaft eine äußerlichkeit könnte
man zwar etwas an etwas anderem etwas an
gute das böse schlecht ist etwas am
guten das gute ist dann die substanz das
ist ein ganz klarer hinweis auf eine
privat theorie der sackgasse auch hier
die privaten ist kein wesen das ist das
könnte man als mutter von thomas von der
queen gelten lassen die prävention ist
kein kein wesen
es wäre so seine theorie auf den begriff
gebracht
hier unten sagte auch nochmal prävention
kommt ihr nur aktien tel vor
also ist alles was ist wie auch immer es
sein mag insofern zahlen das ist gut das
schlechte hat also kein wesen das
schlechte betrifft nicht die substanz
nicht das wesen soll nur diese diese
ordnung das heißt man kann jetzt
so was man hier also das ist gut und das
hier ist schlecht und busse
er bringt ja sogar noch ein paar wir
können mal noch mal er bringt nochmals
was nicht ist ist keines dinges ursache
das ist auch interessant hier ist ein
rückbezug auf dieses fliehen
also das fliegen scheint er gar nicht so
recht als eine ursache zu verstehen sind
er seine wirkung ist eine wirkung
das fliegen ist eine reaktion ich
reagiere auf etwas passiert ich fliehe
es treibt mich weg während das gute das
aktiv anzustreben ist was nicht ist
keines dinges ursache jede ursache muss
als ein sein dass sein dass schlechter
bist kein sein dass also kann das
schlechte keines dinges ursache sein
sollte also ein schlechtes von
irgendetwas verursacht sein so ist dies
notwendig dass gute nur das gute nur die
substanz kann wirken den akzidenz kann
nicht wirken hat keine kraft kann keine
kraft ausüben keine kausalität ketten
entsenden deswegen und das auch noch
interessant heißt ist das schlechte habe
nicht eine wirkung sache sondern eine
mangel ursache eine causa defizienz denn
das schlechte folgt aus einer wirkung
sache nur insofern ihr kraft ab geht
also mangelt das abkehr ist eine prima
zion uns in dieser hinsicht nicht
wirkend ist ja vielleicht einmal ganz
kurzer debatte was was sollten eine
causa defizienz einem mangel ursache
sein
was ist denn das ist es nicht auch eine
ursache bringen sie das nochmal mit
diesem fliehen und streben des ersten
senats entgegen
dieses fliehen wäre gerade diesen mangel
ursache das böse
wie kann man sich einen mangel ursache
vorstellen
haben sie ein beispiel für die ursache
das wäre vielleicht noch viel zu
abstrakt gehen sie mal werden sie mal
ganz konkret was ist ein mangel ursache
wann können sie selbst an sich selbst
alle überlegen das haben sie auch
bestimmt schon mal gehabt immer die
ursache genau genau ich denke das trifft
sehr gut
genau hunger es genau ich muss hier
nicht nur ein falsches essen geben
oder hunger geben um gegeben und jetzt
halt die frage welchen status hat der
hunger ist darüber wirklich nur adäquat
beschrieben als ein mangel oder hat der
hunger nicht irgendwie ins sich seine
positivität ist es wirklich wenn er
hunger hat doch auch eine eigene
phänomenale qualität da soll der zustand
des hungers
also wir scheint technologisch auch im
defiziten so eine art von positivität zu
liegen phänomenologische dass man sagt
hunger das hat ganz klare form jeder
kennt dieses hungergefühl aber von der
kausalität von der entstehung her ist es
ganz klar nichts gegeben es nichts
positives so etwas als mangel
dennoch kam
was diese frage zu richten auch diese
causa den fans nicht perfekt aber das
braucht eine pause
so kommt eine pseudo ursache genau so
die börse
die hervorbringen hervorbringen
und insofern finde ich es eigentlich gar
nicht schlecht das böse getroffen weil
das böse hat diesen du sagt es scheint
so zu sein wie eine ursache wirkungs
sache und so glaube ich funktioniert das
böse dass es den schein erzeugt das sehe
ich dann wieder so ein wenn man ihn so
interpretiert sehe ich da wieder ein
punkt für thomas dass das böse einfach
eine schein produziert ist hat sich als
wirkung
ist dieses abstoßen nicht auch was
aktivem einzige das ich glaube sie haben
es genau getroffen
gegen alle bewegungen der erste bewegung
auf diesem spielfeld an erziehung zu den
guten
dann kann sie mit dem dem
metallgestalter gezogen wird wenn man
ihnen das sicher betrachten
kann er seine oliven unterschiedlichen
beschreibt er ganz direkt zu bestreiten
dass er nach münchen gezogen wird
aber er fragt sie
eigentlich sind gegenteiliger richten
oft wissen oder vielen so ein bisschen
die worte weiß ich woher kommt
beschreibt das einfach als das gegenteil
von dem was irland und dann erscheint es
so als sei dieses gegenteil eine andere
abholen
ja wobei der erste thomas anders und das
was ich dass der baum von je her kommen
in einer bewegung zu der scheinbar so
dass geht es diesen ort möglich aber es
scheint so dass wirklich wirklich
es gibt verschiedene genau verschiedenes
casting aus dem ziel den nbc mit feurig
ist sondern es erscheinen so und ich
kann das auch belohnt aber ich kann
etwas defizite und ich glaube man könnte
nach thomas nicht in diesem rahmen des
magneten denken weil der minuspol der
physikalischen eigene entität ist also
der der da wäre anziehung und abstoßung
letztendlich auswechslung weise zu
definieren die anziehung ist eben die
der betrag der abstoßung wenn ich werde
insofern angezogen als sich abgestoßen
werde alles was vom südpol abgestoßen
wird wird vom markt wohl angezogen und
umgedreht dann wäre aber südpol
ontologisch da und ich denke man dürfte
nicht in diesem sinne des südpols thomas
lesen weil südpol zu und logisch dar
ja genau richtig genau genau aber in
diesem beispiel wären da noch einen
südpol und dann dürfte man so nicht
denken genau und man könnte jetzt noch
mal auf dich zukommt hier sogar auch
sagen auf sie frage ist das das nichts
das nichts ist auf dieser seite nämlich
in diesem diesem begriff dass nichts
steckt genau dieses problem auch drin
wir substanz ihm ihren etwas was
eigentlich substantiiert werden kann wie
die vergangenheit eigentlich nie
erreicht werden kann
das ist das ist dieses problem darstellt
das ist das ist eine quasi substanz
im osten weniger aus dem gar nicht aus
den
ist aber nicht das gleiche
und auch wieder die täuschung mit dass
nichts geriert sich als das sein in dem
es sich ein artikel davor setzt aber es
ist eigentlich grammatikalisch eine
nicht wohlgeformt nicht wohlgeformter
begriff terminus wie auch martin
heidegger vorgeworfen hatten rudolf
karnap hat gesagt heiliger spricht von
dem nichts das nicht nicht sagt heilig
ist das jetzt im vorgriff ist es logisch
widersprüchlicher oder logisch
kohärenter begriff oder satz und darin
zeigt sich es ist also hier könnte man
wieder sagen dass nichts in dem es sich
substanz ihren lässt täuscht uns darüber
dass es keine substanz ist also eine
gewisse spannung in der das verbleibt
werden war da noch eine meldung hier
unglaublich
warum erst jetzt endlich eine reaktion
wird die gute gesteht dass sein team gut
eingestellt
also wenn ich gefragt würde würde ich
sagen thomas und augustinus sind sich
hier sehr entgegen steht also bei
augustinus haben wir hier eine positive
tät eine perversion theorie ganz stark
das böse um des bösen willen da ist
keine täuschung augustinus alle 16 war
wusste genau dass das böse ist und zwar
hat es um des bösen willen getan da ist
glaube ich nichts nicht prävention nicht
so viel prävention der perversion
also das ist erstaunlich dass meiner
sicht jedenfalls thomas und augustinus
zu stark voneinander abweichen
gute frage was denkst du
der eindruck den die entdeckung von
antwortete im mittelalter wurden die
anlagen sowie bei den plastiken
unterlassen
augustinus der wesentlichen faktoren
planung des entwicklungsgeschichtlich
hatte
warum
wenn ich jetzt noch mal das liege im
bett zum beispiel diesen tagen
man könnte einfach sagen das was
augustinus darf ein verein strebt nach
diesen das cockpit zu fordern
das würde das wäre eine möglichkeit eine
andere möglichkeit wäre man findet bei
augustinus viele hinweise auf eine
privatsphäre theoretische theorie des
bösen also es gibt verschiedene stellen
in anderen schriften wo augustinus sagt
das böse kommt aus dem nichts sagt
augustin
also es gibt ein zitat das böse kommt
aus dem nichts im deli beatrice sagte
und die frage konzentriert man sich dann
auch so ein kapitel oder so ein buch aus
den konfessionen aus den bekenntnissen
die er keine theoretische schrift sind
oder konzentriert man sich auf so eine
schulische oder so eine dogmatische
schrift wie dies die libro abi trio dann
würde thomas vielleicht sagen wir
konzentriere mich lieber auf die libori
trio und da habe ich dann die privaten
drin war ja auch jeden konnte keine
wirkliche theorie entwickelt das ist ja
nur der erzählung das narrativ das ist
nicht begrifflich hat kein
philosophisches status oder keine
theologischen dogmatischen status
vielleicht noch ein zitat aber das war
schon ziemlich zentral
jetzt kann man sich fragen ja wie
verhalten sich dann das gute und das
böse das seine das nichts zusammen geht
er zusammen zueinander
und dann sagt er hier was die bisher
gesagten ist aber ersichtlich dass das
schlechteste es sich auch in vielfältige
doch niemals das ganze gute aufzählen
kann vielfältig geht doch niemals das
ganze aufziehen kann und es muss immer
ein träger des schlechten bleiben in das
schlechte bleibt träger des schlechten
ist aber das gute also bleibt ein gutes
immer noch ein zitat dadurch wird auch
der irrtum der mann nicht mehr
ausgeschlossen
die ein höchstes schlechtes arm nehmen
welches das erste prinzip alles
schlechte sei noch mal kurz dazu was
haben sie dazu noch zu bemerken leuchtet
das in ein also wie verhalten sie jetzt
gut und böse gut und schlecht macht
thomas und theologisch zueinander
wir haben es ja eigentlich auch schon
eingeschrieben was das argument
oder machen wir mal eine kleine
pädagogische methoden
diskutieren sie mal eine minute mit
ihrem partner über diese frage ja sie
habe jetzt kurz ein bis zwei minuten
zeit diskutieren immer kurz ihre partner
über diese frage warum
oder wie das gute und das schlechte sich
zueinander verhalten und warum nach
thomas thomas das gute immer bleibt was
für gründe könnte es dafür geben
diskutieren sie einfach mal zwang
dann kommt
gut ich denke die zeit ist warum jetzt
gehen wir wieder ins plenum sie haben
sich ein paar gedanken gemacht bitte wir
sammeln jetzt einfach mal ihre ideen zu
dieser frage warum nach thomas haid wien
das gute immer bleibt und das böse
irgendwie ihm unterlegen ist was für
argumente gibt da hier was haben sie
herausgefunden
einfach mal ganz frei sagen sie einfach
nur ganz frei einfach mal ihre gedanken
das muss jetzt noch nicht so ganz
entwickelt seien einfach nur ihre
intuition dazu wir sammeln einfach mal
ist eine schwierige frage
genau also das rote als solches kommt
nicht vor
das rote kommt immer nur an etwas vorne
das rote kulturen das ist das pult es
braucht um etwas an dem das rot als
aktie den auftritten das rote als
solches die frage ob es das gibt ja
genau das ist also richtig jetzt bezogen
auf diese unterscheidung und jetzt
könnte man dann haben sie noch weitere
gedanken dazu gehabt das ist sicherlich
richtig dass tatsächlich aber ist die
frage
das ist schon richtig die übertragung
aber muss es denn so sein was spricht
sind dafür dass wirklich das gute die
substanz ist und das schlechte nur immer
aktien tel
sein kann was spricht denn dafür gibt es
ja noch so ein argument
gehen sie mal hier noch mal kurz auf
dieses aufzehren auf ssds ihren kanten
aufzählen kann
bitte ja
und warum muss das gute der träger sein
warum kann das böse nicht der träger
sein gibt's dann argument noch haben sie
eine idee also das böse als träger würde
sich selbst irgendwie durch seine
negativität durch seine zerstörungskraft
selbst auf zieren das böse würde sich
selbst vernichten irgendwie es wäre gar
nicht denkbar sondern selbst bezügliche
negation eine negation ihrer selbst wäre
das dann und die negation kann
eigentlich immer nur als woanders
positiven erfolgen
ich kann etwas bestehendes regieren ich
kann nichts das negieren regieren bei
hegel schon aber nicht bei thomas von
aquin
da geht es noch nicht es wäre das ein
logisches argument die negation kann sie
nicht auf sich selbst beziehen da wo
nichts ist und da wohl privat eve agiert
wird die effizienz kausalität
theoretisch da muss immer an etwas
positiven defizienz kausalität
theoretisch operiert werden es geht
nicht an nichts es muss etwas positives
geben ist er so logisches argument schon
fast dafür
finden sie hier
mehr als ein vertrag zustande
das machen sie eigentlich an den zustand
der seite stehen wollen den als positiv
also er sagt einfach dass das schlechte
das ist das verzehrende das private das
glauben
das sind die beraubung muss immer etwas
anderes berauben da wo geld ist da kann
ich nur rauchen ein räuber ohne eine
reiche welt so können sie auch vor
steinen räuber ohne kapitalismus sag ich
jetzt mal ließe sich nicht denken der
wäre arbeitslos es braucht immer eines
positiven positiven kapitalistischen
struktur damit der räuber oder
aufdringlich canary auch im kommunismus
sein aber es muss im warengüter geben
dass er als eine der pendenzen
abhängigkeit des räubers vom besitzen
es besitzt wäre eben das gute dann in
diesem gleichnis na ja also dann hier
noch eben am ende der irrtum der mann
nicht her wird ausgeschlossen warum
werde ausgeschlossen haben sie da noch
kurzen idee wieso kann jetzt auch thomas
sagen aufgrund meines argument hier kann
ich beweisen sagt thomas dass der mann
ist muss wissen sie noch was das war der
mannichl muss also das sagt es gibt ein
gewisses gegen prinzip zu gott eine
eigenständige böse realität dass die
nicht stimmt ist eigentlich ganz klar
oder
also wenn das können sie vielleicht nur
kurz sagen warum muss jetzt wenn das
stimmt hier
wenn das richtig ist warum muss dann
daraus die falschheit des manierismus
folgen
hmm
genau genau dann kann es kein böses
gegen prinzip geben weil es immer nur am
guten es wäre genau genau
wird
genau und deswegen genau und wo man
dennoch neigt man dazu dass die
spannungen neigt dennoch das böse nicht
nur im schwachen aktien zu sehen und hat
immer die tendenz das böse zu
substantiven ich glaube das ist auch
eine tendenz im bösen und so eine lösung
wir jetzt sagen dass nichts das nichts
und daraus ergeben sich dann wieder die
ganzen probleme bei heidegger das nichts
nicht usw
ist das überhaupt wohl geformt dieser
terminus dieser singulären
ich glaube jetzt haben wir sehr viele
punkte bei thomas von aquin behandelt
sie sehen also hier präventions- theorie
ist gibt perversion theoretische ansätze
aber es ist doch sehr stark und
theologisch präventions- theoretisch
verfasst und jetzt hören wir würde ich
vorschlagen weil wir jetzt zum nächsten
thema übergehen zu luther ein kurzes
referat und dann gehen wir mitten in die
diskussion sei disputation die
plastische theologie worin sich bezüge
zu augustinus zur thomas indirekt und
zum manierismus finden immer sehr
gespannt
ja
cham
was eigentlich
[Musik]
ja
vielen dank
du bist der experte peter
das ganze soll
warum gibt es denn gleich vier davon aus
aber das nur nebenbei
worum geht es jemanden der solche thesen
aufstellt solche sätze behaupten und
nicht verstrichen 746 menschen später
nochmals um drei euro
und so hören wir uns diesen dilemma
herauszukommen
ich glaube ich wesentlich schlechter
und irgendwie das zu lösen oder trotzdem
mit der linie kommt dass beide der punkt
und das gegeben nur durch diese
verschiedenen aspekte eines sind also
bei der vergebung doch es ist eben seine
klage die ehre und den glauben ist
natürlich auch dass man irgendwo
deponiert den schritt
diese fonds diese belastung ist schlecht
das problem seines lebens
ich sehe das machen wir nicht der kirche
versteht man aktionen meint dass
passwörter die uhren sichtbar erklärte
weiter und so aber nochmal zu der frage
warum
was ist das haus fragestellung
vor allem diese probleme des glaubens
der schritt ist die frage wer eigentlich
jesus christus ist der gnade der der
fragen der rechtfertigung alles
letztlich nur folgen würde
gelangen gemeinschaft mit gott das ist
die einzige bleiben
weitesten sinne lehrern diese frage mit
einer weise am morgen die ersten falsch
gehalten er war der meinung grundlegend
neue fragen traktieren süßen diese
ganzen dinge im griff und auch eben
diese debatte mit freien bilden ist ein
voller schwung wenn detail und so will
bei seinen versuchen diese frage wie
steht es eigentlich menschen kurzurlaub
und wie können sie ihnen harmonie gerade
sich dem anzumerken dass die frage nach
dem lösung im freien will ist dabei ein
ganz entscheidende der freie wille das
böse sind faktor sind mediadaten vorweg
die lehre harmonie zwischen gott und
mensch zumindest man vermeintlich
entgegenstehen das böse ist etwas aus
den menschen an seiner gemeinschaft mit
gott findet das endspiel ist entfernt
von bord deswegen
und dementsprechend den freien willen
im weitesten sinn der problematik nicht
auf dem tisch tanzen immer wieder hören
die nutzer des informatikers
ja
und da könnte man gleich ein haken und
an den begriff gerechtigkeit weiter
nachdenken gerechtigkeit oder
rechtfertigen hat er diese zwei
bedeutung das war ja so diese justiz ja
distributor und passiver also es gibt
luther hatte wenn ich mich recht
erinnere ist dieses rechtfertigen dass
er in der bibel vorkommt dass gott den
menschen rechtfertigt so gelesen dass
gott den menschen richtet dass er ihn
also über ihn richtet um ihnen dann eben
auch bestraft demir für gerechtigkeit
sorgt und den menschen zeigt dass er
eigentlich nie immer schon von dem
gesetz abweichen muss den zehn geboten
und den ganzen anderen geboten im alten
testament und dann hatte luther eine
neue lesart dieser gerechtigkeit gottes
entdeckt das war er seine so genannte
reformatorische entdeckung und nach eben
gerechtigkeit nicht nur meint gerichtet
zu werden also letztendlich auch
bestraft zu werden weil ja furchtbare
angst hatte in die hölle zu kommen also
da augustiner er mit war sondern dass
gerechtigkeit auch eben gerecht machen
heißt also letztendlich auch etwas
positives bedeutet also die
gerechtigkeit verleihen
also rechtfertigen sollte sagen und
nicht nur strafen und
dass es in diesem satz auch enthalten
also man wird gerechtfertigt also man
wird nicht gerichtet sondern wird jetzt
endlich gerecht gemacht
das ist diese die justitia distributor
wenn ich mich recht erinnere diese
verleihen
die verlierer genau aktiver also die
verliehen eine gerechtigkeit die mann
verlieben bekommt sie als ein geschenk
ist sozusagen und die nicht nur eine
strafe impliziert und das ist dann in
dieser diesem satz wohl auch enthalten
dass man also sogleich gerechtfertigt
ist als auch sünder ist zugleich viele
zusagen solange ca
besucher erleben ist dieser entdeckung
gerecht macht er selber gerecht ist und
eben durch christus sein dass wir dann
sehr auf die person kennt auf die
erlösung letztendlich durch christus
oder in dessous christus sich auch
anschließt an diesen knall und das
arbeits ganz kurz vor weggeschickt und
jetzt wollen wir mal ganz kurz diese
übersicht geben sich noch an die letzte
sitzung haben also dieses thema hier an
möglichen oppositions oder so eine
aufteilung gemacht und jetzt sehen sie
mal wo luther steht also luther steht
praktisch hier das ist das logische
problem so lutter steht könnte man sagen
doch peter einigen august irischen
tradition als er war wie sie richtig
sagt einen referaten augustinerin mit
also hat augustinus exzellent gekannt in
erfurt glaub ich war das ne und er
es geht jetzt auch diese frage ist
erlösung oder justitia gericht
gerechtigkeit ist das möglich ohne
gottes hilfe ohne erlösung gratia
justitia ziele gratia kann es
gerechtigkeit gerechtfertigt zu sein
geben ohne die erlösung durch gott und
diese these dass das möglich wäre dass
man sich letztendlich aus freiheit auch
zum guten entscheiden können
das ist diese position des plagiarismus
und alle anderen modernen philosophen
könnte man jetzt ein bisschen polemisch
sagen kann und wie sie alle heißt alle
heutigen philosophen wäre nach dieser
auffassung
diana
ja die ihm sagen aus freiheit
entscheiden wir uns zum guten wie zum
bösen vor allem zum guten das wäre ein
plagiat und luther wieder richtig glaube
ich es gesagt hast der mutter geht es um
dieses verhältnis gott mensch und um die
faktoren die dieses verhältnis stören
können ja es ist letztendlich auch
wieder bezogen auf diesen paradies
zustand dieses gestörte verhältnis was
wir haben apriori so ein bisschen
erbsünde lehre kommt natürlich auch
wieder einspielen
situation erlebnis das er sich als
praktisch wieder zurück dann und begabte
er kam durch den gab setzen genau was
wir trans labs arisch genannt hatten ja
es ist nicht platzt arischen seine
rückkehr zum relativ in die
gerechtigkeit aber ohne dadurch reicht
es immer zu verlassen
mit einigen problemen die der sündige
welt schwach und das war
es gibt aber er war ein zwitter mit
einem anderen der welt der sind so ist
es eigentlich den menschen
charakteristisch ist ein
zweigeschossiges ein zwitterwesen was
mit partys und nicht mal dass zugleich
immer unterwegs
genau hier können sie ihn jetzt
verordnen
das ist die grundlage die grundsituation
in der in der sich jetzt luther befindet
mit blick auf unser thema die sünde und
das böse und jetzt lesen wir einfach mal
diese aus dieser schrift das ist diese
disputation gegen die show lastiger
etwas bevor wir dann am ende oder der
nächsten sitzung zu beginn auf diese
schrift die servo ag trio com weil der
schrift die wir jetzt lesen werden diese
kurzen die wir auch ungeschickt hatten
als pdf-anhang da finden sie ganz
komprimiert seine position wieder gegen
die plagiat gegen den mann nicht es muss
und auch gegenüber der scholastik die
atome durch thomas vondrak wieder
repräsentiert wird
und auch augustinus spielt eine große
rolle und diesen text den wir jetzt hier
lesen natürlich haben wir noch ein paar
leitfragen wie verhält sich luther zu
augustinus und pelagius was für ein bild
zeichnet luther vom menschen und seinen
willen was mein luther wenn er den
menschen als ein lasst ihr bezeichnet
das betrifft die schrift die servo abi
trio was für ein gottesbild steckt
hinter steht hinter seinen überlegungen
ist luthers verständnis des bösen der
süden präventions- theoretisch oder
pensions- theoretisch zu verstehen
das sind die fragen und zum schluss noch
welche bedeutung hat das gesetz in
luthers konzept was versteht der unter
gnade und zorn
gottes jetzt können wir doch einfach mal
beginnen
ich lese für euch mal vor dass es alle
hören also erstens ist jetzt alles tesla
das ändert so ein bisschen an diese 95
thesen
es ist sehr portier vielleicht könnte es
noch ein bisschen was zum stil sagen
[Musik]
das sagen universitäts abschluss zu
erreichen muss der eine musste these
nicht verteidigen gegen einen gegenüber
und und in sohland verfahren geht es
ihnen um die frage was hat es auf sich
drastisch
diese große tradition
beide kamen in diesem verfahren der das
verteidigen müssen wir das spiel musste
diese argumente prüfen musste und
die thesen von ihnen sind es zurzeit
stecken seine positionen der technischen
für diesen diskussionen in der rede
deswegen immer so thesen für mich weil
ich immer meine these eine gegenthese
zusammen geschoben
die qualifikation eines universitäts
absolventen oder daran dem messer auf
eine lage ist eben auch argumente und
gegenargumente zu richten und so weiter
und überhaupt zu formen nehmen
das ist jetzt modell weil sie
universität zu kunst ungewissen
sie war
ja
wobei man jetzt ein bisschen luther
vorwerfen könnte dass er dann
widerspruch begeht weil ja die thesen
gegen die schüler sticks sind aber die
form der thesen er gerade wieder
solistisch ist als er bringt praktisch
durch die form der scholastik einen
inhalt gegen die plastik vor dass ein
bisschen informativer widerspruch
vielleicht aber wir müssen mal schauen
was sie an kritik enthalten
der moderne sehr skeptisch waren die für
bewegung
für die jetzt wahrscheinlich zu weit als
ich mit der nominell ismus sagte diese
allgemein begriffe beim plattform die
ideen sind lose namen sind lose
abstraktionen sind keine eigene
realitäten die sind allgemein begriffen
wie baum tisch kommt keine eigene
realität zu wie bei platon ist die ideen
haben
der realismus also jetzt nicht unser
heutiger realismus es ist genau verdreht
der realismus sagte nein allgemeinen
begriffe wie baum tisch die existieren
wirklich real die sind wirklich neben
den konkreten objekten und luther ist
also in dem eine domina listige position
vertreten hatte er modern via moderner
er sagt das sind abstraktionen es da
durchaus fortschrittlich in der weise
gewesen das nun mal als hintergrund
jetzt können wir anfangen also erstens
zusagen des augustinus gegen die ihr
lehrer über treibend redet heißt zusagen
augustinus habe fast überall gelogen
gegen eine allgemeine redezeit zweiter
ebenso heißt es den plagiaten und allen
anderen irrlehren gelegenheit zum
triumphieren
ja den sieg zuzusprechen drittens und
das heißt eben so das ansehen aller
kirchenlehre der lächerlichkeit
preiszugeben
viertens es ist also die wahrheit dass
der mensch ein schlechter baum geworden
ist nur schlechtes wollen und tun kann
5 es ist die wahrheit die unwahrheit
dass das frei begehren nach beiden
entgegengesetzten richtungen gut und
böse hin etwas vermag vielmehr ist es
gar nicht frei sondern gefangen
gegen die allgemeine meinung ist das
gericht sechs es ist die unwahrheit dass
der wähler sich von natur aus nach der
richtigen anweisung der vernunft
ausrichten können
gegen scotus duns scotus und gabriel
siebter
sondern ohne die gnade gottes bringt
notwendigerweise ein handeln hervor dass
damit nicht übereinstimmt und böse ist
achtens daraus folgt jedoch nicht dass
er von natur aus böse ist das heißt nach
der natur des bösen gemäss die
auffassung der mann nicht jedoch von
natur aus und um vermeintlich von böser
und beschädigter natur
ich glaube das können jetzt einfach mal
so als orientierung dort so stehen
lassen was wo in diesem ich gehe noch
mal kurz zurück kennt dieses schema hier
wo genau also ist jetzt mutter hier
anzusiedeln wenn sie sich das noch mal
als inter kollegen sie haben vielleicht
auch eine zusammenfassung hat sie jemand
noch nicht vor sich will sie noch jemand
haben dann schauen sich nochmal hier
dieses grafik an und dieses zitat und
dann versuchen sie mal hier
luther mal noch mal ein bisschen zu
verorten hier mit gewissen argumenten wo
kann man initiieren diesem schema was
wir hatten unterbringen
also gehen wir mal einfach einmal von
vorne nach hinten
wird er der auffassung seien dass
augustinus gelogen hat und die
unwahrheit gesagt hat wie verhält er
sich zu augustin und das kann man sich
direkt daraus hervorgehen wird er hier
augustinus er verteidigen wollen nach
dem ersten satz oder er kritisieren ja
genau
also man kann hier schon mal eher zu
augustinus hinnehmen das ergibt sich
auch daraus das hat auch daraus
plausibel dass in der zweiten these sagt
dass es bedeuten würde wenn man
augustinus schlecht macht dass man den
plagiaten gelegenheit zum triumphieren
gibt was er offensichtlich nicht möchte
als er es gegen die plage an
und jetzt geht es aber sogar noch weiter
jetzt geht es eben darum ob wir frei
sind
das gute und böse zu wollen wie wie
sieht es damit aus mit dieser frage was
sagt jetzt luther über die freiheit zum
guten und zu lösen
da seine meinung dazu
ja also entscheiden sind offensichtlich
these 4 und 5 in these 4 sagte er
es ist wahr ist die wahrheit dass der
mensch nur schlechtes gleich böses
wollen und tun kann also eine
asymmetrische freiheit also eigentlich
nur zum schlechten frei würde ich jetzt
sagen nur zum schlechten
und naja die these 5
dann sagt er es ist die unwahrheit dass
es das freie begeben nach beiden
entgegengesetzten richtung in habe aber
in these 4 sagt doch er habe die
freiheit zum zu einer seite wie ist das
jetzt so verstehen sehen sie darin
widerspruch in these 4 sagte es ist wahr
dass der mensch sich mehr oder weniger
zum bösen entscheiden kann oder es
wollen und tun kann das ist ja die
freiheit zum bösen der gewissen weise im
these 5 sagte es ist falsch dass das
freie begeben sich nach einer oder der
anderen seite hin schreiben kann liegt
darin ein widerspruch oder nicht es muss
ja nicht ein widerspruch zu sein aber
primär fatih ist darin widerspruch
enthalten
die vernunft ist genau die vernunft ist
anders als bei kant bei kant ist ja die
vernunft die instanz die uns das gute
vom bösen unterscheiden lässt die uns
mehr noch sogar zum guten animiert und
motiviert die vernunft sind so ein
subjekt substanz bekannt fast schon hier
ist er sehr sehr kritisch
also die es gibt keine vernunft aus
natur die uns irgendwie ein licht
aufgehen lässt sondern da ist natürlich
wieder sola scriptura solar fiel die
ganzen soli sind hier ausschlaggebend
natürlich so eine einschätzung aber so
einfach darf man es nicht machen also
und seinen stücken 8
dann dürfen eben genau zu sehen bekommt
schrift zu lesen und so weiter also
benutzt er selber vermuten seine these
verschätzte
aber er ist ganz hektisch was die ziele
angeht erreicht nicht zu zu gott
vorzustellen vertrauter von gibt nicht
zu letzte wahrheiten nicht zu aber das
möglich
er ist also gewissermaßen vernunft
kritiker könnten zu haben aber halt in
einer anderen weise als kann ja aber
noch in einer anderen obwohl bei kannte
ja auch ich musste das wissen aufheben
um platz zum glauben zu bekommen das
geht doch auch so ein bisschen in
luthers richtung kann war ja auch
protestantisch geprägte weil es
vielleicht kein besonders
das hat klare um 1900 enorm von den
fluten
aber noch mal ganz kurz bevor sie noch
mal drankommen genau nochmal ganz kurze
der frage zurück ist zwischen these 4
und 5 widerspruch enthalten also
inwiefern kann ein these 4 sagen dass
wir zum bösen frei sind und in these 5
dass wir weder zum guten noch zum bösen
frei sind
dann sind wir nicht frei
ja also praktisch
[Musik]
man könnte schon sagen also das wäre das
argument ihr um wirklich frei sein zu
müssen brauchen wir beide alternativen
wenn wir nur einen weg haben sind wir
nicht frei aber wir können es wollen und
tun also wir könnten etwas wollen und
tun ohne darin frei zu sein dass eine
unterscheidung kann man sagen muss
begrifflich nicht dasselbe zu sein
man könnte es ja wollen und tun weil man
von natur aus dazu programmiert ist
aufgrund der erbsünde zone sind wir
einfach aufgrund des alten adams in uns
wollen und wie wir das böse sind daran
aber nicht frei sind prädestiniert
hmm
genau hier genau das wollen aber nicht
frei wollen warum nicht weil es könnte
man mit harry frankfurt diesen modernen
amerikanischen philosophen argumentiert
weil er keine koalitionen zweiter stufe
hat er hat nur volition erster stufe
also dieses gegebene wollen dieses diese
erst stufigen munition die er in sich
auf findet aber kann sich dazu nicht
nochmal reflexiv erhalten und diese
volition beeinflussen will endlich kann
darüber nicht frei entscheiden über sein
will
er hat also keine willensfreiheit aber
er hat handlungsfreiheit
das hätte auf jeden fall
handlungsfreiheit weil er kann das tun
was er will
these 4 wollen und tun wollen plus tun
können heißt handlungsfreiheit zu sein
aber eben nicht willens frei zu sein
weil er eben unvermeidlicherweise seinem
willen den er durch die erbsünde geerbt
hat dem folgenden folge leisten muss das
sind interessante entscheidung wobei es
gibt jetzt thesen der neueren debatte
die sagen auch bei luther gibts sowas
wie willensfreiheit das geht dann in
dieser richtung das hat der mensch folgt
seiner natur und in dem er seine natur
folgt ist ja auch willens frei das macht
seine identität aus
da gibt es ein riesen debatte darüber
gab es eine debatte jetzt im letzten
wintersemester über luther und erasmus
da kann ich ihn auch noch den link dazu
schicken können sie sich die ganze
diskussion nachsehen auffiel lukas ist
ja auch nicht aber das nur bis dahin das
war da noch eine meldung ja
es ist eine art von determination brede
termination finden sie sonst hier noch
irgendwas interessantes schauen sie mal
auch in these 7 noch mal hier
schon ohne die gnade gottes bringt der
notwendigerweise ein handeln hervor dass
damit nicht überein stimmt und böse ist
also wie bringen sie dass es zusammen
mit dem was wir hier schon gehabt hatten
als inwiefern kann jetzt der mensch frei
sein wodurch wird der mensch ist frei ja
indem er eben die gnade gottes erhält
peter würdest du damit über
einstellungen kann der mensch wird
dadurch nach lothar frey dass er befreit
wird und das in freiheit durch gnade
verliehen wird könnte man das so sagen
kann man so interpretieren
die mutter hat ja auch eine positive
stimmung geschrieben die auch sehr weil
verbreitung fand die der freiheit gehen
und zwar um seine angst befreit nicht
gebunden freiheit den menschen betrifft
diesen glauben geht von der freiheit des
christenmenschen
doch es ist ein dienstbarer knecht und
jedem untertan und der crysis 1
allerdings weiß ich widersprechen
ist total frei wer ist überhaupt nicht
zu
insofern gehe ich freue mich auf das
zusammentreffen mir kommt es so vor als
sei damit eigentlich sagen und menschen
so schnell vorbei als etwas in ihm frei
ist wenn ich gott also wirklich frei
sein kann der mensch für sich
es kann nirgendwo ausführlichen wirken
und damit auch die freiheit
also insofern der menschen glauben ihr
gott in kontakt stehen gott zu gefährden
ist er ein freier mensch und mache
niemandem untersagt
insofern der mensch so vorsichtig wie
der mensch menschen der 100 prozent
sicher unter druck setzen
das heißt in den kopf frei machen es
nicht der ddr
und das trifft dann auch wieder dieses
berühmte bild gleichnis was wir in der
nächsten sitzung noch mal kurz
besprechen werden mit diesem lasst ihr
wo als einmal der teufel den menschen
reitet auf ihm sitzt um ihn lenkt und
einmal gott und nur wenn gott natürlich
auf ihm reihte dann ist er frei
das noch
das ist ja das große drama in der so
wäre würde jeder mensch tagtäglich in
den wenigsten überleben will ich doch
nicht gerade wenig noch genau
aber der kann sich für den glauben
entscheiden dann kannst du das zu
entscheiden ist aber zu blau
das ist das große mehrheit ist der
schmerz ist ein spiel der kräfte ist
völlig falsch zu glauben
dann kommt es hingegen zu glauben aber
nicht
vielleicht noch mal ganz ganz kurz bevor
die meldung kommt es geht eben bei
luther auch diese ganz berühmte
formulierung dass wir nicht auswirken
gerecht werden gerechtfertigt werden sie
nur aus glauben und dann kann man sich
natürlich fragen sola fide wenn wir nur
aus glauben gerecht werden kann man da
nicht doch sagen dieses aus glauben dass
das irgendwie unserer macht liegt das
liest man jedenfalls so wie gesagt nicht
durch werke also ich kann da noch so
viel geld spenden und noch so gebeten
und so oder was ich es gegen den ablass
gerichtet auch noch so viel
ablasszahlung bezahlen diese werke diese
äußerlichen werke bringen nichts ist
aktivität könnte man sich fragen solar
viele ist dieser glaube dann ist dir
dann nicht doch auch eine zurechenbare
aktivität jetzt nicht vielleicht zum
werk charakter hat so die effizienz wird
kausalität sind diese einstellung
bedeutet die wir gegenüber gott ein mann
ist nicht dieses hersteller einer
bestimmten einstellung und zurechenbare
also würdest du sagen selbst das ist
nicht
viele ansätze sticht dieses
verschiedenen sole- und so ließen die
solide sich die so klar zu machen dass
man sie nie auf 1 festlegen kann man
dass man sich untereinander bedienen
also alleine der glaube ja klar aber
dann komme ich den süßen glauben allein
din a3 auf selbst kann den glauben
erreichen wie komme ich denn zu dieser
gehabt und für mich weiß ich eigentlich
die kann wie man auf der welt schlüssig
erklären ich kann zu erkennen und
christus das ist der einzige christus am
kreuz das ist das einzige was mir gerade
wollte es überhaupt klagen mehr fahre
ich noch immer nicht christen
unterschrift sonst auf der welt jemand
diesen christus näher bringen aber ich
verstehe ich den begriff schrift durchs
leben gewesen sondern nur durch die
schrift im tiefsten verstehe den geist
versteht dann werden nur durch kranz ja
nicht die allein durch die gnade habe
ich die möglichkeit des stifts überhaupt
zu stehen was entsteht wenn durch diese
schrift stehen wiederum klaue das
brauche ich an was bringt mir dieser
finde dass ich christ verweisung system
ein verwaltungssystem was
eine systematische lehrern über thomas
volk entgegen wo man sagen kann aus dem
vollen dass das ist dann haben wir das
ergebnis anders sein
eine eigentlich nicht sehr lebhaft
werden einen verständnisvollen glaube
was sehr dynamisch sehr schwer zu
begreifen dass deswegen heute auch kein
glaubensstärke keine abgeschrieben in
europa hinaus wäre kein dogmatiker in
ganz europa
dass leute mir sehr einen das leuchtet
mir ein es war da noch aber das ist eher
ein also alles verweist auf andere alles
reicht sich so gut wir kommen ja ein
ende
wir bleiben in diese abhängigkeit und
jeder jede und das bringt ja auch deinen
punkt wieder vor dass wir auf diesen
widerspruch hingewiesen so los heißt ja
allein war einzig aber so dastehen so
viele soli und soli deswegen weil eben
alles aufs andere verweisen
und darin ist es eben nicht verfügbar
darin ist es nicht verfügbar zumindest
dieses fide würde ich sagen wäre noch
verfügbar also auf ihre frage hin glaube
kann ich schon irgendwie aufbringen aber
der glaube muss motiviert sein der
glaube muss eine grundlage haben und der
ist abhängig irgendwie aber ich würde
sagen von allen diesen ist vielleicht
noch dieses diese einstellung die am
ehesten unserer freiheit zuzurechnen
zuzurechnen wäre ich kann versuchen mich
zu öffnen gegenüber sohn gottes
verhältnis so eine basis zu schaffen
aber würde er sagen das reicht nicht der
glaube muss fundiert seien in diesen
anderen momenten
er versucht gläubiger zu werden freunde
zu werden entfernt
versuche unterbunden werden wir
versuchen wirklich gut dass ich es
überhaupt möglich geworden
um das zu erreichen um diesen glauben zu
erreichen der eben das gefühl von gnade
und fertigung von einem kneten gott
überhaupt erst verschafft oder gemerkt
der tat am fasten übungen als studien
die dinge behandelt davon entfernt
glaubenskrisen gegenüber kaffeemaschine
je mehr das ich muss im moment hat also
dass er eigentlich kann ich nichts dafür
tun viel grazie christus unser erreichen
genau man könnte sich hier noch frage
ist es nicht vielleicht dann wenn es
schon keine hinreichende bedingung für
das heil ist oder die rechtfertigung ist
es vielleicht notwendige bedingung also
notwendig ohne fide geht's nicht ja aber
mit
wir haben uns noch nicht ganz ist es so
wir müssen es haben ohne das geht es
nicht aber es bringt doch nichts allein
so sind notwendige bedingung vielleicht
sozusagen dieses
vielleicht verstehen
also warum kommen manchen die hölle und
manchem himmel wenn sie es doch selbst
nicht zu verantworten haben ist es nicht
einfach
dieser verschwand das dass dieses große
bewegen menschen die eben weil sich auch
jeder in lustiger musste nicht
christentum ein völlig falscher
durchgeführt
damit waren bis vor schritten zum
beispiel eben diesen dich christian
dadurch eigentlich genau das sagen haben
wird er im dezember erscheint
und wenn sie innerhalb dieser
verschiedene wege gehen und sein passend
zur zone zu jeder und haben wir liegen
vorne geben
dieser dogmatische ist ermittelt werden
und 2001 gesperrt
man müsste glaube ich schon noch getauft
müsste glaube ich schon auch getauft
sein also taufe ist für mutter ja auch
so ein sakrament
er kennt ja eigentlich nur sehr wenigen
zwei sakrament und abendmahl und die
buße noch so ein bisschen geld aber die
taufe ist halt ganz wichtig verlud also
diese taufen und die wäre ja da in
diesem fall da nicht vorhanden
ohne dass ich mir jetzt genau ausgang
das könnte so ein hindernis dafür seien
nicht christliche menschen
die größeres tier ist gerade was nicht
allein 100 frage nach der sogenannten
kataster kantonen also der saison
prominente stadträten die frage ist das
evangelium in der familie nicht in
letzter konsequenz zu entnehmen dass
durchaus auch hier sind es die die
gesamte welt
durch christus schon
jetzt auch einmal gegen die völlig neue
testament dass sie sich schnell
herausgestellt so pflegen als antwort
die eltern sich versöhnen sich wohl aus
dem signal aus keiner mehr auszahlen
klammer auch auch nicht wie gar nichts
von anderen müssen es gibt aber auch
lehrern die auf jeden fall sicher
behaupten auch die findet
das ist ein richtungsstreit erregendes
tätig und zählt also nicht
meine heilige land entscheiden
und das ist natürlich eine knifflige
sache also ich mach das dürftige mensch
etwas zu erzeugen was die menschen
ernähren kann ich den stoff verfügen
kann die kamera auch mit den schaden
die
weil man das dann auch wieder auf luther
zurück beziehen kann
doch einiges hier das ist ja nicht
irgendwie einen automatismus der hier
stattfindet
strengt eine vernünftige anfrage ist
darin nicht irgendwie auch willens frei
in dem was er tut wenn er schreibt oder
ist ja auch nur sprachrohr letztendlich
brauchen wir wirklich keinen spaß dann
ist das also kann für linke fühlt sich
ganz gut sich viel wohler als wir damals
gar nicht klar heraus sagen gibt darüber
wie sie in einer städtischen verkehr
also fern
er löst ist bei ihnen noch ein punkt der
ist tatsächlich eine riesen erreichte
das ist nämlich die der frage komme ich
der beste bin ich
mehr nicht zugesprochen wird das nicht
dass selbst das ist glaubt zu entlassen
also dass der mensch informationen
müssen religiösen angelegenheiten nicht
frei ist
das muss jetzt klare schon früh war
erlesen erlösen und entledigt den
menschen die ganze seele wenn ich was
muss ich tun
und ist ja fast auch in zu sehen
die lage sich zu
deswegen kann es auch bleiben lassen ich
kann das schicksal
nicht gibt
werde nichts was es geht erstmal sehr
dunkel und vertrag das bleibt aber in
diesem dunkel fatale haben und was er
erreichen dass insofern ja es ist
bekamen diese dunkle seite bleibt eben
auch dabei
das wird nicht gestrichen
ich glaube das ist ein gutes stichwort
jetzt auch die sitzung zu beenden wir
haben auch viel diskussionsstoff ich hab
sie auch noch gesehen dass nehmen
vielleicht nächste sitzung mit über weil
da wird mir in der ersten stunde uns
noch mal sehr intensiv mit dem zweiten
text befassen nämlich über die
unfreiheit des willst die servo ag trio
im gegensatz zum augustin ischen die
libero abi trio wir werden ihnen eher
normal ein paar leitfragen herumschicken
und werden an der zweiten hälfte auf
leibnitz com und werden dann wohl auch
ein referat glaube ich hören ist die
referenten der referent da das schauen
wir dann noch mal auf jeden fall werden
wir zu leibnitz zurückgehen dann bis zur
nächsten sitzung